Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, and since there
have been so many questions about what’s
going to be happening this fall in terms of
videos and stuff I’m doing, I wanted to
do a trailer video explaining my updated video
schedule.
This will cover everything between September
right now and December.
Including shows, movies and even the video
game channel.
Some of you might know about my not so secret
video game channel charliestreams.
There is so much awesome stuff coming you
have no idea how excited I am.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time.
My name is Charlie and I like Fiction.
There’s also some really important business
that I’ve woefully neglected.
We are almost at 400,000 subscribers here
and first of all thank you for being amazing.
But we need to think of a name for ourselves.
Right now I’m thinking The Legion sounds
really nice.
But while I explain the plan start thinking
of names.
Here we go, I’m just going to do tv shows
first by which day of the week they’ll be
on.
Starting with Mondays.
This is going to be Gotham and Star Wars Rebels.
Gotham is the Batman Prequel show on FOX.
It starts September 22nd at 8PM Eastern Time.
All the time slots I’m going to mention
will be in Eastern Time, so just adjust based
on which time zone you live in.
It’s going to be told from the perspective
of Detective Gordon, played by Ben MacKenzie.
The number 1 reason you need to watch this
is because it is going to feature almost every
Batman villain you can think of.
Hugo Strange and Arkham Asylum will be heavily
featured.
And there’s this great running gag where
supposedly the main villain owns a comedy
club, and a new “Comedian” auditions in
every episode.
Just as a funny way to tease who they’ll
cast as The Joker.
Even the super haters in the blogosphere that
have seen the first episode were blown away.
Tonally it’s going to feel more like a really
dark cop drama with superheroes in it.
Donal Logue, who’s playing Bullock is going
to be so much fun to watch.
Next is Star Wars Rebels, Disney bought Lucasfilm,
so this is going to air on Disney XD starting
October 13th at 9PM, so see, things are already
working out.
You can watch Gotham first and Rebels right
after.
The number one reason you need to watch Rebels
is because right now is the beginning of this
unprecedented thing in the Star Wars Universe,
where all of the movies, the tv shows, the
novels and the comics exist in a shared universe.
Star Wars under Disney’s watchful eye, is
doing the same thing Marvel is where things
happening on the tv shows affect what’s
happening in the movies and vice versa.
Since Rebels is a prequel show about the time
between Episode 3 and Episode 4.
It will give a lot of the background about
what’s going on when Episode 7 picks up.
They are making slight modifications to the
original film canon.
And Rebels will explain it all.
Moving on to Tuesdays:
Agents of SHIELD, The Flash and Supernatural
are all the Tuesday shows.
Agents of SHIELD and Supernatural air at the
same time, so I’ll explain how I’m going
to fix that problem.
Agents of SHIELD is the first thing to premiere,
it’s coming September 23rd at 9PM on ABC.
They already confirmed that Hayley Atwell
will be in the first episode as her Agent
Carter character.
Probably in a flashback.
But the number one reason you need to watch
this is all the new Marvel characters they’re
rolling out and the overlap with the Avengers
Age of Ultron movie.
Next is The Flash with Grant Gustin, that
premieres October 7th at 8PM on the CW.
I’ve already been doing a lot of bonus videos
for this.
The number one reason you need to watch it
is because it is also the beginning of an
unprecedented time in DC Comics television
where characters from each of their four shows
get to overlap.
The Flash will mostly bounce back and forth
with Arrow characters.
Characters from both shows will guest star
in each other’s stories.
The mid season finale of Arrow and The Flash
will be a two hour crossover event.
Seriously, it’s going to be freaking amazing.
Your faces will melt off.
They’ve got a huge list of comic book characters
they’ve already cast including Firestorm
and a bunch of people from Prison Break.
Moving on to Supernatural Season 10.
It’s premiering right after the first episode
of The Flash at 9PM also on the CW.
This overlaps with Agents of SHIELD.
So what I’m probably going to do is I’ll
still post a video for the premiere.
But I might just do Supernatural videos in
some other way.
Probably as a blog post or something on tumblr.
For those that don’t know, I do have a website
called EmergencyAwesome.com, I just haven’t
posted anything new there in a year.
So I might use that do funny Supernatural
stuff.
I need to make it look all shiny.
Moving on to Wednesdays:
This will be Arrow day.
That premieres the same week as the Flash
on October 8th at 8PM on the CW.
I did videos for all of season 2 and everyone
loved it, so if you’re new to the show and
you haven’t been watching it.
The number one reason you need to is they
are basically doing Justice League on TV way
before the movies ever get there.
Even just between Arrow and The Flash, we
get a one hour Justice League episode every
single week.
I don’t have any videos planned for Thursday
shows right now, so that will be a catch up
day and just a time for me to post other fun
stuff and bonus videos.
Friday will be Constantine.
That’s the fourth DC Comics TV Show.
It’s starting October 24th at 10PM on NBC.
The number one reason you need to watch this
is the same as Arrow and the Flash, it is
going to heavily feature characters from the
comic books and will fill that magic gap in
the DC Universe movies and tv.
Right now magic doesn’t exist on Arrow or
the Flash.
So Constantine is like the magic-based Comic
Book show.
They even just cast the Spectre.
I haven’t done a lot of bonus videos for
this yet, but I will start in the next week.
I got to see the first episode at comic con
so I’ll do a non-spoilery review.
Then Saturdays, Doctor Who Series 8 will continue
until November 8th on BBC America or the BBC
depending on where you live.
New episodes air in the UK at 7:30 GMT and
9PM on BBC America.
If you’re not watching it yet, the episodes
are made to stand alone by themselves, so
you don’t have to worry about not having
watch everything that has come before.
I feel like a lot of people new to the fandom
get put off by the sheer quantity of Doctor
Who there is.
But I do a ton of bonus videos.
So those should help you get up to speed.
Of all the Science Fiction shows I do, this
is my favorite.
I consider the comic book genre to be different.
Sundays will be Walking Dead season 5.
That starts October 12th at 9PM on AMC.
I did videos for all of season 4 and everyone
had a lot of fun so same drill as last year.
The number one reason you need to watch this
is Machine Gun Rick is going to fuck shit
up I know I don’t swear a lot, but Walking
Dead is going to get really hardcore.
I will still be doing Game of Thrones bonus
videos and Legend of Korra, but I might shuffle
the days I post those videos to make room
for the new stuff.
So I’ll announce those kind of schedule
changes when I post bonus videos for those
things.
On to Movies.
I know a lot of you have requested more Movie
videos and I will continue to do all the Marvel,
DC and Star Wars stuff but here’s an early
list of movies I’m doing videos for between
now and the end of the year.
This month there’s Maze Runner and Boxtrolls,
remember that stars Bran from Game of Thrones.
In October there’s Dracula Untold, Princess
Kaguya the new Studio Ghibli film and Horns
the new Daniel Radcliffe movie.
In November there’s a bunch of stuff, The
new christopher nolan movie Interstellar,
Big Hero 6, Hunger Games Mockingjay, the new
Benedict Cumberbatch movie Imitation Game
and then in december is The Hobbit Battle
of the Five Armies.
That’s the final Hobbit movie by the way.
I know a lot of you have been requesting video
game stuff.
I am going to start doing more stuff on that
channel now that I’ve finished moving apartments.
I’m mostly a steam game person just because
it’s more convenient for streaming.
But my copy of Destiny is on Xbox One.
I’ll make more separate videos explaining
how my video game stuff is going to work.
But my video game channel is called Charlie
Streams if you’ve never seen it.
So subscribe to that if you are interested
in more video game stuff.
I also have a twitch channel called emergencyawesome.
I’ll add links for everything in the description.
So lots of awesome stuff coming, I totally
would not spend all my time making videos
for things if I didn’t think they were amazing.
Just to give you an idea for when videos will
post for all these things, generally videos
for episodes of tv will post within about
3 hours of them airing on tv.
On days like Mondays and Tuesdays when I have
two shows, I’ll do the first show video
that night and the next one the morning after.
So things will post in the order they air
during the week.
So Monday shows will mostly post on Mondays,
and so on.
I will live tweet as much as possible, so
you can follow me there.
I’m @awesomemergecy on twitter, but everywhere
else, facebook and instagram I’m emergencyawesome.
Links for all that stuff in the description.
I hope that gives you an idea for what’s
coming, I’ll do another video like this
later in the year when everything goes on
break.
But if you have any questions about shows
or what the videos are going to be.
Just ask in the comments.
Right now click here to start getting ready
for The Flash and Arrow and click here to
start getting ready for Agents of SHIELD and
all the Marvel stuff.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!